- Salut la Team Mentalo !
Aujourd'hui je suis avec Chris alias Poisson Fécond
- Oui Blouc Blouc Blouc
c'est moi
on reconnaît un petit peu le salon
*Charabia incompréhensible*
... Quand je filme mes vidéos
Mmh ...  N'est-ce pas ?
- C'était compréhensible,  ce que t'as dit ?
- Bah oui ... J'ai ... Hein ... Allez on enchaîne ?
Attends je check ma montre Steampunk ...
Exactement deux heures et demie  du matin
- J'avais l'impression de voir Parker Lewis
*Rires*
Synchronisation des montres
Il est deux heures et demie du matin et on a trouvé que c'était une très bonne idée
D'en profiter, de ce moment et de cette heure pour parler du fait d'avoir des problèmes pour s'endormir le soir
Donner des clés ou des techniques ou des conseils à ceux qui tournent et qui virent durant des heures
Dans leur lit sans trouver le sommeil
- Bah y'a l'ASMR hein ...
L'ASMR  c'est un truc un petit peu bizarre
Donc c'est des personnes qui chuchotent qui  font des petits trucs comme ça, ils grattent des objets
Et ça peut être très relaxant, peut-être que vous y êtes sensibles à ce genre de choses et vous ne le savez pas
Allez regarder
Je fais , donc quand tu parlais du Verseau, c'est justement ça que je fais dessus, c'est des vidéos de relaxation
Et j'écoute très souvent ce genre de vidéo, presque tout le temps en fait, avant de m'endormir
Je met ces vidéos et puis ça m'aide à faire dodo
C'est essentiellement le truc, après il y a l'hypnose ou l'auto-hypnose  ou alors ...
y'a un truc qui est cool aussi c'est que vous comptez votre respiration
"1  2  3  4 , je retiens, 1  2  3  4 et ça finit par nous ...
nous soûler en fait et on s'endort
- Alors, la technique complète du "'4 -7- 8", l'idée c'est de  mettre la langue derrière ces incisives, de bien la coller au palais
- Incisives c'est où ?
- Le haut
- D'accord, au palais là comme ça ok
- Tu tiens là, comme ça
Une fois que t'as fais ça pour le premier coup bon tu vides l'air de tes poumons
Vous pouvez essayer de faire ça, et ensuite de bien inspirer par le nez en comptant jusqu'à 4, mais vraiment, une fois par seconde
une fois que c'est fait de bloquer et de compter jusqu'à 7 et une fois que c'est fait, d'expirer en comptant
jusqu'à 8 et par la bouche toujours en ayant la langue comme ça
- Et ensuite dès qu'on a expiré on ré inspire ?
- Exactement
- Il n'y a pas de période où on a les poumons vidés ?
- Non, il n'y a pas de blocage  en poumons vidés, c'est en poumons pleins
- D'accord, moi j'ai connu d'autres trucs, le "8-4 8-4", il y a le "5-8" aussi, le "5-7" ... enfin y'en a plein
- Ouais, ben là, le "4-7-8" le but c'est l'oxygénation, au contraire, c'est quand t'as les poumons pleins
et après, comme ça  ils se chargent et tu peux tout vider d'un coup
L'oxygénation qui va améliorer le rythme cardiaque qui va vous faire du bien
vous pouvez essayer ça, c'est une technique qui a été découverte dans une université américaine :
La langue ça va permettre de se concentrer et si vous le pratiquez régulièrement, au bout d'un moment
en temps normal c'est sur un cycle directement que vous allez vous endormir parce que, comme tu disais
très bien, ça va te soûler un petit peu et tu vas partir
La technique vendue commercialement parlant, on te dit "En une minute, tu dors avec ça quand t'as l'habitude"
- Ok, je savais pas
- Et en picolant un peu
- Ça aide le picolage
Sinon il y a aussi euh ... sans la technique "4- 7-8 " juste l'alcool ça peut marcher
-La technique 8-6
-Est ce que tu fais apparaître le message " l'alcool est dangereux "
Tu peux le mettre partout parce que quand je vais dire qu'il faut prendre une bouteille de rhum entière
Ensuite vous dormez directement
Bah après il y a les ondes euh ...  alors si je peux rajouter mon grain de sel
Bien sûr c'est le but
c'est que si on connait pas les ondes alpha, donc le cerveau il est calibré sur certains types d'ondes
Bref. il va se mettre à vibrer comme ça comme un "marteau piteur" ?  Piqueur ?
- Piqueur.
- Un marteau piqueur, quand on est à l'état de veille il vibre comme ça
Ensuite ça détend quand on commence à être relaxé et le marteau vibre de moins en moins et les ondes alpha
c'est celles qui sont les plus basses
*Soupirs* Il me faut un schéma parce que moi sinon je comprend même pas quand je parle
- Après sur des choses, des conseils un petit peu plus pratiques et un peu plus évident mais ça fait toujours
du bien de le rappeler, en général on a du mal à s'endormir parce qu'on est parasité par les choses
qu'on a à faire, par tout ce qu'on a en tête, par les idées qu'on a, par le fait de se coucher en se disant
"Ah oui put** il faut aussi que je fasse ça demain, ça demain, ça demain"
Il y a  une chose très bête mais qui fonctionne bien
c'est avant de se coucher de se décharger sur du papier
L'orgasme c'est fait ça on en a parlé c'est bon ok
de se décharger mentalement sur du papier en se faisant une espèce de " To do list" des chose qu'on a à faire
qu'on a laissé en suspens avant d'aller se coucher
- Moi ça m'excite, quand je commence à écrire enfin je me met à écrire je me dis
"Oh ! mais y'a ça, y'a ça y'a ça " ce qui fait qu'à quatre heures du matin je suis toujours à écrire
Je fatigue parce que j'écris trop
- T'es trop prolifique aussi ...
Je sais pas du tout ce qu'elle va rendre cette vidéo en termes d'énergie c'est terrible hein
- C'est à dire, en termes de dynamisme ?
- Ouais, d'énergie tout court
- On va cut les blancs et puis ...
*Rires*
- Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on a beaucoup parlé avec Chris, c'était passionnant, toute la journée
toute la soirée, ce qui fait qu'on tourne très tardivement et c'est super, je me suis
abreuvé de conseils,  d'expériences
- Et de même, petite anecdote, à côté du sommeil, vous dormirez plus tard, c'est que ce cher collègue
c'est que il a enfin je t'ai fait visiter un petit peu Grenoble notamment la forêt, là où il n'y a pas
de lumière
- C'était tellement glauque, y'avait pas de lumière mais on arrivait à voir les cadavres de toutes les bouteilles et de
papiers chelous et de tout ça autour de nous
- Tu t'en souviens encore ? ça n'a pas bien fonctionné  le poison
- Voilà c'était un petit panel de plein de techniques différentes, de débuts de pistes
On peut en parler dans les commentaires si vous vous avez d'autres méthodes qui vous aident à vous endormir
Ou si vous voulez que je reprenne un peu plus en détail une autre méthode, je pourrais aussi vous répondre dans les commentaires
pour tout le monde voilà sur le "4-7-8", sur autre chose
Vous pouvez aussi aller voir sur la chaîne du Verseau
des choses très interessantes en terme de relaxation  et en plus de ça, si vous avez pas pris les vidéos
depuis le départ, vous devriez pouvoir rattraper toute la chaîne du Verseau assez rapidement et ça ...
- Waow ! Comment tu me vends ! Waow ! C'est beau
Bah voilà je n'ai pas grand chose à dire d'autre, ça vous donne pas mal de petites pistes si vous avez du mal à dormir
- N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
puisque le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
Merci beaucoup à Chris
- Et ça c'est intense et ça se salue
- Merci !
- Merci Fabien !
- C'est parce que je savais pas encore que c'était compliqué
Merci à Chris Poisson Fécond
Si le hasard fait que vous ne connaissez pas Chris
Je vais vous mettre un bandeau cliquable ici, tous les liens dans la description
Merci à toi Chris !
- Merci Fabien !
- Merci de ta concentration, de ton dévouement et de ta gentillesse
- Oh ... C'est rien du tout
- J'ai l'impression d'être un wesh
"Merci"
- "Ouais vas-y représente vas-y le dodo, à toi et moi !"
- "Le dodo fécond "
Merci rendez-vous demain à 17 heures Ciao !
- Bisous les gars !